selection starts today in a lawsuit
against former president Trump his
lawyer says he has no plans to attend
the trial former advice columnist e Gene
Carroll claims Trump attacked her
decades ago then defamed her when she
went public many years later she never
reported the alleged assault to police
and first shared her story with the
public in her 2019 autobiography
by then it was too late for a criminal
investigation but a New York state law
allowed Carol to file a civil lawsuit
Trump has repeatedly denied the
allegations he called Carol's claim a
hoax and a lie used to promote her book
and said quote she's not my type more
than a dozen women have accused Trump of
sexual assault or harassment he denies
all the allegations and none of those
claims have gone to trial until today